[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is Bob
Crawford Bob Crawford from The Avett
Brothers I am such a huge huge fan of
the Avett Brothers huge fan of Bob as a
person not only as a bassist and
vocalist and fiddlest and occasional
Trump trumpetist for the Avett Brothers
one of my favorite bands in the world
but he's also one of my favorite people
in the world he's incredible he's deep
he's thoughtful he's beautiful and I had
this chat with him it was a while back
uh but we sat on it for a minute and I'm
happy to be finally releasing it with
you guys uh and I spoke to him in his
home over the zoom zoomables and I'm so
glad we got in touch you guys need to
see them live The Avett Brothers are
currently on tour which is something
that I'm just like I'm not even close to
done being grateful for the fact that we
can tour again the Avett Brothers we can
go see the Avett Brothers again go to
the Avett brothers.com tour for tickets
to those if you go to any of them that
are in California take a look around
you'll probably see me in val there
Hooten and Holleran along with you don't
Hoot and Holler during this you know
after the songs not during the songs
don't be that guy I'm also this is the
silliest intro I'm also going to be on
the I am on the road I guess you can say
even though it's not you know I'm
recording this at home but go to
petehomes.com if you'd like to see me
live doing stand up it's the where were
we tour I'm so thrilled to be back with
live audience crowds in cities other
than Los Angeles thrilled thrilled
thrilled thank you to everybody that
came to Toronto Atlantic City Boston up
next is Chicago which is sold out except
we just added a late show on Saturday at
the Den theater so please come out to
those it's going to be so fun to be in
Chicago the city that I pretty much I
know I did a few times in Boston but I
consider Chicago to be the city where I
learned how to do stand-up and it's
always so fun to come back so please
come out to the den go to petehomes.com
for tickets that's November 10 11 and
12. after that San Francisco Portland
Seattle Atlanta Charlotte and Washington
DC and hopefully we'll be adding some
more dates very very soon and if you
like this show why not try you know this
why not try a pizza pick ads for things
that I actually use and actually love
like living Libations living Libations
has done a complete overhaul of all of
our hair skin teeth and baby products we
are a living Libations family it all
started because I realized I was being
very careful about what I was putting in
my body when it came to food but I
really had never given it any thought
about what I was putting on my body
sunblock
skin care moisturizer all of these
things are are often filled with a lot
of chemicals that you just don't want
getting into your body and the things
you put on your body do get into your
body and that's where living Libations
comes into play this is a great way to
support the show because they have
little things and they have big things
like we use their zinc based sunscreen
it's called love the sun Leela is in
preschool now which means every morning
we have to slather her head to toe in
sunscreen and just with the littlest
amount of effort at looking on Amazon
all the stuff that they call Natural or
they call Natural and and like some sort
of alternative to chemical sunblocks
they're still filled with chemicals I
don't know what's going on here it's
like a huge hoax if you want an actually
natural actually zinc based sunblock
that works fantastic feels great on your
skin and you can put something on your
kid that you don't feel terrible about
use living Libations their love the sun
sun screen is incredible and also use it
on yourself I mean you're worth it I'm
going to tell you you're worth it I use
their Ginger exfoliating scrub which is
not only natural and made with
ingredients that I can recognize and
pronounce but it's also one of the most
not one of the most it's the most badass
exfoliant I've ever used in my life use
it before you shave the razor just
Glides it Glides baby through the Zen
shave Zen shave is living Libations is
living Libations as uh shaving bomb
which again is so clean the ingredients
are so clean and so natural you can
actually use a dab of it as your
aftershave try doing that with some
Anonymous neon blue goo that you buy at
7-Eleven whatever you need great way to
support the show face body eyes teeth
even baby products living Libations has
a premium natural and wonderful product
to replace the random chemical nightmare
they sell at 7-Eleven go to
livinglibations.com and use promo code
weird capital w eard November capital n
o v e m b e r weird November both first
words capitalized that's the code for
this month you will get yourself 15 off
and you'll be doing your face your skin
your teeth whatever it is your body a
favor and showing your support of the
show that's livinglibations.com promo
code weird November get into it secondly
do you love podcasts uh yeah you do
you're listening to this one right now
or even better maybe you're thinking
about starting a podcast or maybe you
want to record an album or maybe do
voiceover for that cartoon series that
you've been wanting to upload to Youtube
well all of those things start with
Incredible microphones and you know they
need to be amazing they need to give you
that amazing in studio quality but if
it's possible we don't want to pay that
huge Studio costs well guess what blue
microphones have got you covered I'm
speaking into a blue microphone right
now this is the Sona uh it's the blue
Sona XLR mic which is very high-end it
sounds incredible it's the best mic
we've ever owned ever used but we
actually started this podcast with
Blue's most famous mic which is the Blue
Yeti it's their USB mic that you can
just plug right into your computer and
start podcasting start animated
recording whatever you need to do with
voiceover with recording music it sounds
great even if you're new to recording it
requires absolutely no training or
expertise it's truly Plug and Play It's
also the only USB mic I found that has
different settings for solo sitting
across from another person and
omnidirectional for when you want to
record every sound in the room literally
never found another one with all of
those different settings and is also so
easy to use so so cool it's made by the
same company that makes high-end Studio
mics that have been used on so many
major huge hit records same Technologies
Behind these ones blue have been around
for more than 20 years and today blue is
part of Logitech for creators and as I
mentioned if you're watching the video
I'm touching it right now this is the
blue Sona XLR mic for podcasters we use
this and as you can tell it's up to our
game quite a bit so what are you waiting
for if you want to do it and do it well
anything with your voice with music with
sound go to
bluemike.com and use promo code weird
for a special deal on any blue
microphone and show your support of the
show again that's blue
mike.com you're my boy blue
and use promo code weird for a special
deal on any blue microphone and show
your support of this show last but
certainly not least is one of the OG
Pete's picks which is on it Alpha Brain
Alpha Brain has absolutely
revolutionized how I am a creative
person and how I get my work done and if
you do something that involves your
noodle your brain your thoughts your
memory your focus I promise oh I'll
speak for me Alpha Brain has made my
access to my own brain my own thoughts
my own creativity my focus and my
concentration so much more natural
effortless and easy it is not a
stimulant it's not caffeine it doesn't
get you jacked up in fact I like to take
it off and before I go to bed because it
gives me very Vivid and interesting
dreams which I also love but if you take
it during the day it's not going to give
you dreams you're just going to be able
to focus and get into that flow state
that much easier I have Alpha Brain in
my car I have it in all of my travel
bags I often have it in the pockets of
all of my jackets I've had fans come up
to me and ask me for Alpha Brain and
I've taken it out of my jacket pocket
that's how much I love it and if you're
doing something that involves your brain
if you're a student if you're a Creator
creative type or honestly Val and I just
had a wedding anniversary I took a
couple Alpha Brain before I date just
because I wanted to have access to my
thoughts to my memories to to be focused
to be present to be locked in Alpha
Brain is a huge huge huge game changer
if you like it one tenth as much as I do
you're gonna [__] your pants and I
promise uh well for me it's helped me
get my work done if I don't take it I
absolutely absolutely notice the
difference it is a huge secret weapon
Earth grown ingredients Game Changer
best way to see if you like it is to
give it a try and you'll be showing your
support of the show go to on it
onnit.com weird and you'll get 10 off
everything you see on that landing page
that's on it.com slash weird you'll get
10 off everything on that landing page
and show your support of the show and
support and support your brain support
your Clarity and your memory okay this
intro this intro's over
so glad I got to finally sit down with
Bob Crawford from The Avett Brothers uh
get uh uh get into it you look great
look at you you're all you like I'm all
sweaty and uh you have a you have an
upright uh base behind you and who is
that is that uh Merlin who's that do you
know who that is do you have an original
Merlin behind St Jude that is Saint Jude
kid I don't know much about Saint Jude
that is the actual photograph of Saint
Jude from before he was killed by arrows
I don't know how to break this to you
that is not a photograph that's not a
photograph maybe it's a derogatype
uh what is a derogative type it is the
earliest photographs
there is one of the giant there's one of
John Quincy Adams it's uh the first
president to be photographed was John
Quincy Adams and it's I think actually a
deroga type is the
the method that is the name of the guy
who did it
would they project the image through a
lens and then paint it no no this is a
photo I've heard of that it's really
awesome Graphics I will send it to you
yes it's it's out there I have it in a
book on the shelf that you can't see
because I don't oh it's on that shelf
right there right there you want to show
off those built-ins see you you got you
got a nice little setup going I love it
uh well thanks for taking the time man
tell why Saint Jude let's you know it's
funny like I do feel like I have to be
like so Bob how'd you get into avids and
and all that stuff but like I'm really
excited to talk to you because we have
so many shared interests but I feel like
we have to like hook them a little bit
them the listeners the people joining us
right now and be like Bob's in the he's
in the Avett Brothers everybody and
that's that's why we're gonna listen to
the rest of our God talk and our on our
discussion on all of that Theology and
good stuff but I want to give a little
bit but but before we'll jump ahead why
Saint Jude oh because my daughter is a
patient at St Jude Children's Research
Hospital she has had three
brain tumors
sent through a brain tumor at 22 months
old and two recurrences her last being
September of 2020.
which it was like the most 20 20 thing
that happened in 2020 to us yes was our
daughter having a seven year remission
of brain tumors which you don't get a
seven year mission
you mean that's unusual to come back
after seven years like I think it's it's
unusual well these are all rare and
deadly of course and um
but once you get five years that's a
pretty good place to be
and so for hers is really super rare and
I mean so rare that you know she was
diagnosed with one tumor and I can go
into the names of them but it'll just
people make people more confused
um but so she was diagnosed with one
brain tumor here in North Carolina rare
deadly uh we did second opinion at Dana
Farber in Boston and Saint Jude and they
said no it's actually an astrocytoma
glioma rare and deadly
um but so we went to Saint Jude it was
literally on a wing and a prayer because
at our home the UNC Chapel Hill they
said there's really nothing you can do
we can pull up some chemo protocol off
the shelf and maybe that'll give you
some time but but there's really we're
talking about quality of life here not
survival
so this is um this is in August well
we've got the Saint Jude October of
2011. she was diagnosed August 28th of
2011.
and so we arrive at Saint Jude with no
hope
but the hope of Saint Jude who was the
patron saint of the hopeless cause
and so that's why because I knew Saint
Jude was the was the cancer hospital
obviously but I didn't know why
um for the Hopeless I can go into the
history of the hospital that involves
Entertainer Danny Thomas if you'd like
or we can skip that but I will give you
the really because this is this is this
is pertinent
um Danny Thomas who
was other than being you know in
addition to being a great comedian and
singer and Entertainer and back in that
he wasn't in the Rat Pack but back in
that era the creating times the crooning
times he was he had his own he had the
Danny Thomas sitcom and he also became a
great producer and produced and created
The Andy Griffith Show among many other
great
um classic uh sitcoms so anyway Danny
Thomas was a struggling uh Entertainer
and his daughter Marlo Thomas had just
been born and he was in Detroit and he
had 15 bucks to his name
and down on his luck he goes into the
Saint Jude Cathedral
and praise to Saint Jude and lights a
candle says if you give me a break you
give me my big break you give me just a
chance something to hold on to here
I will do something great in your name
to honor you and he put eight of his
fifteen dollars in the in the in the
prayer bucket and next day he got a
radio ad
and from the you know doing voicing a
radio ad and then he got another gig and
then he got another gig so years go by
he's very successful very famous and
Cardinal Stritch who was the Archbishop
of the Cardinal for um
Chicago
said to him Cardinal Stritch I think it
was weird
that is it was stretch I can tell you
that stretch is is that's like stretch
is a stretch Hatchet are you saying I'm
saying it's like nurse ratchet it's like
a name that you sound like you're in
trouble just based on who wants to see
you well he he was because he said Danny
remember the promise you made to Saint
Jude
and so how do you feel about it I
because Danny Thomas was a fit he was a
a cat like a very Catholic he slapped
his gums and said I made a promise yeah
I promise well yeah and and he was also
uh Lebanese uh second generation his his
father came over from Lebanon and so he
was second generation American and
actually the fundraising arm of Saint
Jude is alsac which is the American
Lebanese Syrian Associated Charities and
so so they decide to the The Good the
good Cardinal or Archbishop and Danny
decide to do
um to create a hospital for children
with catastrophic illnesses and they
formed this American Lebanese Syrian
Associated Charities and they go around
the country and find all these
successful
Americans of of Lebanese and Syrian
descent now one of them for example was
a man named Richard shadyak who was a
justice department lawyer
uh and so there's all so all these guys
get together and they begin to fundraise
for this for this hospital that they're
going to build in Saint Jude's honor and
they don't know where to put it and Dan
and and the Cardinal says I think
there's some we have a hospital in
Memphis Tennessee
that like a Catholic Hospital that maybe
isn't doing well and I may not be
getting all this exactly right but
basically they they have there's a
Catholic connection to a hospital uh in
Memphis Tennessee and the other thing
that was attractive about Memphis was
that it was very poor
and so if you have a hospital for
catastrophic areas and you put it you
could put it in New York put it in
Chicago you put in LA but if you put it
in the South it's somewhere where
there's a great need
so so they decide they're going to put
this Hospital
in Memphis and they start fundraising
and who fundraises for this thing Elvis
Presley
Frank Sinatra
Sammy Davis Jr all the all the all the
Heavy Hitters of the time so the
hospital is um
I believe it opens its doors
in 1962 I believe I believe but they
groundbreaking like 59 or whatever and
so anyway Danny Thomas one of the
greatest Americans of the 20th century
at the very least worthy of his worthy
of his postage stamp and
um uh what I like about the story Bob is
that and this isn't a bit he needed the
nudge human beings are good but we're
better together he made the promise uh
you you could say like oh yeah but then
he forgot and then and then uh nurse
ratchet had to say hey wait a minute but
that's actually what's lovely about
that's one of the many lovely things
about that story and even the humility
to include that that they weren't shy
that that was part of the story and then
it became this Collective thing but it
started I guess what I'm saying is I
take Hope from them I have moments we've
all thrown Hail Mary passes and and had
prayers where we're like I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna do this but it's when
when human beings get together other
huge things happen right oh yeah because
we can't do it ourselves no see I mean
to clean that up Showbiz wise is you'd
like to make that a movie somebody would
want to remove the moment where someone
said like hey didn't you say you were
going to do something for Saint Jude you
would remove that because we want Iron
Man you know what I mean we those are
our modern mythologies we don't want uh
and by the way I'm not calling him
broken I'm saying we're all broken and
we're all in need and my wife Val is
that for me so often I'm an achiever and
one of the things that Achievers can do
is is they can sometimes forget who's
helping them or who's helped them along
the way and Val is very good to be like
hey uh [__] and and yeah and I'm just
like oh God at least you recognize when
you're wrong and you go like oh yeah we
need to we need to make that right or
make that right or whatever so I love
that's the part of the story that really
stood out to me
um obviously the fact that all of these
people these great people came together
I'd love to see Elvis fundraising and be
like a little less conversation a little
more donating you know that's right well
there are pictures right there are
pictures of Elvis on a stage with Danny
Thomas and wow yeah because Elvis being
from Memphis as well so it was and Jude
the history of the the hospital I mean
they've it was at St Jude in the 80s and
90s that childhood leukemia went from a
20 survival rate to an 80 survival rate
80 plus wow so they've had the Nobel
Prize winners and the you know it it
went on to be I'm sure he when he passed
away that was what he was most proud of
being a part of and uh there's a another
great aspect of Saint Jude was that here
you go you're in this deep south during
the time of and just after segregation
and so you would have kids who came from
all over and you would have you know
white kids and black kids and the hope
there was no housing at that point at
Saint Jude so
um
the hotels would say well they wouldn't
provide housing for the black kids
and Danny Thomas said if you don't take
the black kids I'm not going to give you
the white kids here
and so he really decent helped to
desegregate Memphis and it's crazy to
think even at our age I'm like I can't
fully imagine what a big move that was
we're like of course and everyone will
support you and everyone will cheer and
it's like now when he said that a lot of
like whoever it is whether it be
probably people not associated with
gospel but probably some people even
associated with the hospital we're like
no that's insane that's insane so he
would stand I'm trying to bolster that
move it wasn't as easy you or I would be
like pretty we need these all the people
and and now everyone would cheer
thankfully more people would cheer but
back then the majority was actually like
what are you nuts like exactly
thankfully hard to get my mind around
it's never as in it always seems
inevitable right like today the day that
we're speaking is the 80th 75th
anniversary of D-Day and you know I've
heard this a hundred times today but
it's just like it wasn't inevitable
right that the Allies were going to win
the war and Hitler would be defeated and
the world would be made safe for
democracy and for at least that 70 years
that we had we had it
um but that wasn't inevitable of course
it wasn't this is what I'm saying that's
the removing of cardinal uh stretch or
what was it strips
you're going to make me look all this up
too bud we removed the stretch from the
stories we we want just inevitable
Victory but no story it's certainly no
story worth telling but no human story
is going to be that clean of course
everybody was was nervous about about
D-Day are you crazy of course yes but
you know we look back and we give it a
nice glossy glossy shine
um so that's why Saint Jude you know man
I do want to just jump into it because I
I love talking about this stuff I'm a
parent first of all thank you for
telling that that story of course I I
know it from the movie I watch you guys
on CNN so I've heard you tell it a
couple times obviously it's so weird
actually that would be interesting to
talk about it's like it's become a thing
that you talk about and that has to be
strange right I mean there are certain
experiences in life that even though
they're unwanted they they have a
certain sacred or unspeakable let's say
unspeakable quality but then it becomes
like what service is Bob to the world
what service is your family's story to
the world if you don't talk about it but
was it hard to kind of get over that
hurdle of like I have to imagine when
your wife finds your baby having a
seizure
that's like the last thing on your mind
is like I'm gonna get good at recalling
this and and even breaking it down into
beats and even having an awareness of
like how much is too much like I need to
don't forget to close on Hope Bob people
don't want you on CNN not closing on I
hope yeah there's like a cultural cancer
talk dance that we do would you talk a
little bit about that because because
it's beautiful what you're doing but I'd
love to know how you've uh transitioned
into
surviving that to guy who Now talks
about it it's almost like what happened
and then there's the way we talk about
it right sure yeah well well let me just
say for all the hope that there is and
there's a lot of Hope and if it wasn't
hope and if it for me if it wasn't hope
it wasn't faith I I couldn't go on I
couldn't talk to you right now I
couldn't get out of bed in the morning
you know my life would be uh just a dark
and gloomy place you know and it's it's
hard but but but there is hope and
there's joy in the pain and the sorrow
and we'll get to that
um you know as you said that sorry for
lighting up but I'm like buddy so many
people this is this is it this is what
we're talking about and too much of life
has become texting or or social media or
movies or just talking about pants and
that's one of the main reasons I'm
excited to talk to you where you find
that hope where you find that faith and
and finding the joy and the suffering
and also
when it's not joyful too like all of it
you know what I mean so please consider
this your safe space because I really
believe people need to I need to hear it
as well so let and I'm here for you too
you are not burdened with reminding us
all that there's hope I am here for you
as well so I don't feel like you have to
push it up the up the hill but we're
talking about talking about it and and
and go go wherever you were going just
then yeah so well you know you mentioned
it my daughter was for those that don't
know uh the band was coming home from a
European tour it was our like our most
successful for us you know our most
three and a half weeks in Europe and it
was really successful for us and and we
were we were um on cloud nine and uh we
the plane lands in Charlotte North
Carolina from Germany I turn on my phone
really excited because my son was just
born two months before that
and yeah I've been gone for almost half
my son's life like at that point and um
those are unfair fractions don't yeah
don't beat yourself up in those factions
and uh you know but but my daughter was
22 months old and um turned on the phone
and my wife's like
honey I just Hallie you know she's in
the hospital something this she's like
and my wife was just so poised and you
know crying
um and struggling but but just like
this woman had just experienced the most
traumatic moment of her life
and uh you know she she went to get
Holly out of the crib she's having a
seizure she's doing this thing called
posturing where her arms are stretched
out and her hands are bald into fists uh
her her left eye is is moving she was
essentially having a stroke like she was
having seizures and she was probably
having a stroke because she had several
Strokes that day and so my wife gets her
downstairs she calls 9-1-1 9-1-1 comes
they go to the hospital all this time
I'm I'm in the plane I'm completely
unaware get to the hospital they they
intubate her while she's awake so my
daughter lets out a scream while they're
putting the ventilator down her throat
and my wife for the moment was like
thank God she's alive like just that was
a sign that that Hallie was still alive
they do imaging they find a mass in her
brain that was a quarter of the size of
her brain at that time
um at that age as you will probably
remember our skulls are soft until about
about that time is when they begin to
Harden so she essentially had this mass
in her head this tumor and it was
allowed to grow larger and larger and
move things out of the way like it had
moved her the right side of her brain
into the left side of her brain because
of um the softness of this of the skull
so wow yeah so that's probably why this
was the moment that it presented itself
she had she'd vomited a little bit a
couple days before but you know you
called a pediatrician and it's like oh
kids do this thing and and you know and
then then she came around you know the
night before she was actually doing
better they they went to get ice cream
and things since she was on the floor
coloring you know things seemed to be
moving in the right direction so they
get to the hospital Hallie needs to go
into surgery it's emergency surgery we
don't know what's going on yet and this
is pretty much what I call and so she's
trying to explain this thing to me and
oh can you talk sorry about you tell me
a little what was you've talked to your
wife about this moment how was she
anchoring herself was it shock was it
did she have to
she was worried about me
she was worried about like because she
knows me
and I'm a mess I'm sorry I I mean of all
the things yeah like I could be fighting
tears this whole time but that that that
is there's something beautiful and human
about yeah by the way you and I both
know by right she could have been
freaking out that would have been okay
but and she was you know in her I know a
human way you know yes please nobody
misunderstand that she was no no she was
but she was poisonous
to think of that that's a a heroic love
right there that's really beautiful she
had called our manager and had him meet
me at the airport because she knew I
couldn't drive the two hours when once I
got this information she knew
I would be unable to physically drive
myself the two hours from Charlotte to
Chapel Hill
Ary
came and got you yeah yeah and so so the
craziest thing is like Scott and I we
had um on the way we had upgraded
ourselves to First Class like the band
were all Joe Kwan and and Seth you know
they're all on coach and and Scott are
like hey let's let's just treat
ourselves here so we uploaded ourselves
at the last minute so he and I flew back
in first class and just like had the
loveliest conversations and talked about
music and and it was and our kids
because his son you know he had
you know his daughter Eleanor and then
his son Max is only two months older
than my son and so we were both you know
so excited to come home to our our young
families and and you know we're going to
work with Rick Rubin and like the the
few we had been working with recruit
like the future yeah at that moment was
was bright it was just really bright can
I just say sorry to interject but it's
like it's this
it's almost fitting meaning it's like
there's you're flying
you're you're dealing with what we are
normally dealing with things like
airplanes it's things like first class
upgrades and and good conversations and
stuff and I feel like we're all on this
tightrope all of the time and this this
is some of the relief I want to give we
all know
that were skating in a mystery you know
God makes plans uh man makes plans God
laughs that sort of thing we all know
that Bob and even though we're both
fighting tears right now yeah I'm like I
I I think it's a gift to talk about this
like something about the European tour
went well the flight got upgraded it it
rings cosmically true that there's so
many stories not just your story so many
stories that are like talk to people on
death beds that are just like
why are you so stressed out or why are
you mad at your cousin because they are
awoken to the potentials of of all the
infinite possibilities and and there's
something cinematic about what's
happening I I'm not excited about it I'm
just saying no but it's look it's coming
for us all like like yes that's it
that's right we are in the earliest days
of this
um we had a Doctor Who
we had a doctor I'll just say that and
she said um
you don't get through life without
something like this happening
you know and then we would have older uh
people come like like Scott and says
parents would came to the hospital and
to see us and they said I remember Jim
saying this is well older people
experience this not people your age like
this is you know you get older you see
tragedy you experience tragedy it comes
it comes close you know maybe you know
your parents pass and you know you just
you see you see stuff you live you see
stuff and but you know for us at that
age
though I was 40 um but but I mean that
wasn't the being at your 22 months old
bedside you know when she's that clean
life isn't typical
um right so so but so the plane lands
you know I call my wife she she does her
best to explain what's going on and I'm
you know my heart's dropped and I'm not
in I'm having a panic attack or
something I'm in shock
and at the moment Scott's like what's
going on what's going on I'm trying to
explain it to him and then the TSA or
whoever stormed the plane because there
was like a threat on the plane and
they're just like um that you remember
that you have the guards on the plane
after 9 11 they start putting those guys
in the Marshalls and the Marshalls and
there's like you got to get out of the
plane you got to get out of the plane so
so I'm trying to explain Scott what's
you know going on I can barely move he's
like literally you know guiding me like
I'm a 90 year old crossing a street you
know off of the plane I explained for
him I explain it enough to him and he
literally guides me through customs and
explains to them you know gives them my
passport and says this guy just got some
really bad news and like literally Scott
got me through customs and then I get
through and I guess the word had gotten
out because I see that our band members
and and you know they I guess Darth told
them something was was really going
Hallie was in the hospital and it was
not good and I could just see this
worried like this distance it you know
after this happened no matter how close
I was with anybody
Scott and Seth anybody like there's
there is a a gap right there's just a
distance because you've experienced this
you know
no you're telling this beautiful story
I'm just saying that's what I'm saying
these these moments where where Scott
merges with you yeah it says it's this
thing
and again
I hate this story you know what I mean
the street it's a horrible story and and
there's these weird he wouldn't have
grabbed you like that literally carrying
not I don't mean no no you can yeah no
you can yeah and there's your band and
you can finish what you were saying it
sounds like your heart shatter open it's
like Leonard Cohen the cracks are how
the light gets in right right suddenly
why do we have the death bed I love you
Dad scenes it's because the sledgehammer
how are you going to say it removes the
distance right it's right yeah yeah and
so and then I see Dolph and then we this
and this is the most beautiful one of
the many because you're right like
the light light gets in the cracks and
and you know my wife and I we were
crushed but the kindness that we
experienced you know over the the course
of this is just far and wide and deep
um and um one of the first earliest acts
you know besides Dolph coming to to take
me was um was Scott getting in the car
with us
and he had not seen his family
in over three weeks and without thinking
or or thinking
like this guy needs me I don't know he
got in the car he went to Chapel Hill
with us and and Dolph had brought a
friend to drive my car
to you know home for me all that way two
and a half hours so it's it's me Scott
and doff in golf's car driving to Chapel
Hill and then Dolph's friend Brian
uh driving my car following behind you
know and well you know just this this
really
and it was frustrated by my wife
no you know and because because she
didn't know what to do so she called
Dolph and Dolph was like you know let me
I'll do whatever you need me to do and
and um yeah it's just a
it just it's just incredible so so we
get to the hospital and we go in the
emergency they told us to come in the
emergency exit and on the way
um
you know Melanie you know we had another
couple conversations and it was just it
kind of felt like I was
she wasn't gonna make it you know what
I'm saying it just it just it just
seemed like you know we didn't know it
was happening she was in surgery this
whole time she's in surgery
and so we get there and and this this uh
one of someone who works with an
administrator at the hospital guides
Scott and I up this back elevator as as
Dolph's parking the vehicle and we go up
to the sorry about just one one detail
are you sure are you locked up
completely locked up at this or is the
are the emotions coming uh yeah yeah I
mean I was
at this point I'm like I'm like
somebody's got to hold Bob someone right
well there were times where I was just
so calm in the on the car ride that I
was
I was mad at myself for being so calm
because why are you I didn't feel
anything I was numb like this is like
people say I was numb that would I would
say but then I would be
just a mess
you know it's just really weird when I
saw my wife it flowed and of course her
family was there and these people I just
we our friends had get like people had
gathered at the at the picu waiting room
you know in Hallie's in surgery and and
and the people we love are there and my
wife and I embrace we look we look each
other in the eye and it's like this
moment of like yeah we're we're doing
this like we're doing like we're in this
and we're doing this yeah that's right
like it was this affecting you like go
ahead yeah it was just very affirming
like like I know like she would have to
tell you her side of it but but for me
it was it just it was like we like we we
had we were the only two people in the
world
you know who were experiencing this and
we had each other we had each other
um I wonder by if the
I I find sometimes in moments of high
stress and I'm not going to clear my
throat people when they talk to you they
must you must hear constantly not to
compare to you all that sort of like
grief uh right sort of pp measuring the
suffering Olympics we call it Discovery
I'm not even talking about a specific uh
moment I'm just relating to you that
sometimes it's free is that you kind of
go into that fight flight and sometimes
there's like a
like a numbness and out of bodyness sure
and and I I wonder
like uh moments in my parenting I've
I've felt where Leela had a lot of
um UTIs when she was a baby and there
were moments where Val you know were new
parents and she's just going like I
think something's like really really
wrong and for some reason I would just
be completely like this is okay we will
go to the like and I said to Val later I
was like I feel like if she was calm I
would have freaked out but it like
balances it's like one of us at a time
I'm the freak out I'm the I'm the I'm
the you're the freak out I am the
freakout King to this day tell me maybe
it's gotten better I don't know I hope
she walks in you can ask her but but I
mean yeah but it's it's um uh yeah she
she she's like um has gotten to be
because obviously we have you know
Halley will be 13 I don't wanna I don't
want to like like skip over to like the
Happy thing but you know she was 22
months old when this journey began and
she said your man she's here yeah you
know November 1st you'll be 13.
so you know she's has multiple uh
disabilities and and so it's been it's
been a rough we've had a rough ride with
her but you know we know the joy right
but still you know to this day like my
wife's like what she like I'll be like
what's going on what do you think's
going on what things happen he thinks
he's a guy I'm always like
I'm watching I'm watching you know she's
you know she's more let's observe
and and let's kind of like gather the
dangerous thing and then yes and then
but I'm like both I'm calling the doctor
you know like yeah both are needed
though yeah I'm the one who won't call
the doctor necessarily obviously we have
your limit but I'll be the one that's
like I'm sure it's fine let me just walk
around with her I'll be calm that'll
calm her down and all that sort of stuff
but you need Val Leland needed a
whatever like she needed the thing yeah
so it takes both yeah so I'm just
celebrating Bob obviously we're
celebrating your wife too but it's those
two energies that balance one another so
so I love I love obviously again I I
have to say I'm excited by the love and
the and the compassion in the story and
I'm saddened by everything else but the
moment of and the detail of looking in
each other's eyes I have to think
almost like a carb crash it has to be
you're nowhere else in the world right I
mean you're you're not you're not
thinking about your presence your
present and I'm not saying that's a
silver lining I'm saying that has to
make it a peak experience it has to be
yeah well I go to therapy like I see a
therapist right and um and not every
week I probably should uh
um I don't know about you but sometimes
that gets more like oh I'm good and then
you don't see the therapist and then
like sure everything goes down you're
like uh you called
what's up
I'm currently not meditating and I'm
like something's wrong and I'm like Pete
how many times you need to ReDiscover
that you need to be meditated
maintenance what is therapy maintenance
yes yeah and it says it's like me
looking at my Bible you know for me like
as far as like reading either either
reading scripture or reading um you know
a a thinker you know know I'm saying
like when you're not nourishing
something that that feeds you yeah you
need to nourish it but but um
oh man I just lost I just lost uh we're
talking about oh about being present
right so so I I saw her a couple weeks
ago and I said um
you know it's all about being present
isn't it and my wife would be like I've
been telling you that
for that 16 years
at least your therapist is a woman and
then you can't be like oh now that a man
told you when when
um when I think about the worst things
that could happen in not just to my dog
but to my daughter frequently I think
about the bad outcomes and then just I
think about bad outcomes from us on I
think about bad for myself for you know
for all of us
um and
that's like that is not being present
and it's like because because even when
we're getting to this like getting back
to what happened with Hallie in that
moment in the hospital it's like
when the really bad things happened they
aren't they pretty much don't happen all
at once all the bad feelings you have
does it doesn't all happen at once and
um when you're present to it uh it's
more digestible as awful what it is
you're you're you're living it you're
greeting the moment by Moment by moment
and you're you're getting through it
because you're actually living it and
experiencing it have you heard this of
course anxiety is paying interest on a
debt that isn't yours is a quote that I
love my wife says borrowing trouble
borrowing trouble yeah I've also heard
praying for something you don't want uh
that one's a little superstitious
adjacent I don't think that's how it
works that if you worry worry then then
no I do that all the time like my
negative thoughts and my anxiety will
not put a brain tumor in my daughter's
head that's right that's right and it
won't it won't crash your car and like
you know there's something uh that's why
I don't love that one it might make me
play a bad bass note
I will say it does work in the small in
the small term for sure if I went into
this conversation and was like I don't
like I I will say before we start this
this is going to be great we are both
gonna love this this is gonna uh people
are this is their favorite episode that
sort of stuff because it does help in
the short term but I don't think I can
you know I don't even want to say the
examples of you know break your window
or whatever that's not that's not how it
works but I do think it's interesting I
think it's brilliant what you're saying
is that when we're suffering
one of the ways to relieve it is like
what like ask yourself what are you
suffering for and often for me and for I
think a lot of people it's something
that you're forecasting into the future
that hasn't happened and probably won't
happen even if it's likely let me put it
this way Val and I have been saying
lately what's the problem right now
and so many of us Bob not just in you're
dealing with the capital letter tragedy
things but in most things our brain I
actually thinks it gets a perverse
pleasure you're a Bible person I think
obsessive thinking dwelling
um inability to let go of a fantasy
these are like demon possessions these
are possessions sure sure they rob you
without a doubt it happens to me all the
time I get and if I'm exhausted and like
you know you're only hungry for a while
or hungry hangry right yeah yeah I am I
am more susceptible to it little things
will happen I mean I did it on the road
this weekend with Scott and I was like
Scott this is kind of bothering me right
now uh just you know it's just like I
just you know that's just I've reached
that that moment yeah and it's just you
know the these things it's it's always
lurking if you're not nourishing
yourself
that's right ways
buddy I was just talking about this
because I was I just I'm seeing a
physical trainer I can't wait to tell
people that's not true uh but I we were
seeing if a trainer or that you can't
wait to tell people it's just
embarrassing that I can't I can't wait
to tell people that I'm seeing a
physical Trader but we were just today
talking about this podcast and I was
explaining a little bit about what it's
about and cleaning up before you wake up
and something have you heard that
expression no like some people just want
to jump to the spiritual okay Bob and
Peter talking about being present Bob
and Peter talking about when you're
suffering sometimes you're suffering an
imagined future like or your imagine
future is making your present moment way
worse that's right even in even in 10
out of 10 nightmare suffering you can
slow down and drop and drop anchor into
the present and deal with it and that's
biblical too the the concept of God not
giving you more than you can handle
that's right well you you might you
might build out but if you slow down but
how do you do that often you know I
think the fact that you're in a good
relationship for example the fact that
you're creatively fulfilled the fact
that you live in North Carolina like
that's no small thing that you've
decided to like live in a beautiful
nature place right uh that you have so
much to be grateful for the fact that
you're meeting your needs the fact that
you have what were the things that kept
coming up in that story Dolph Scott Seth
family these that's cleaning up like
before we jump to like you can handle
anything if you break it down into the
moment sure but that's going to make a
lot more sense when you have your game a
little tighter like just your
psychological game your social game even
your professional creative game that's
that's been one of the big breakthroughs
for this and then also on a small scale
maybe you need a maybe you need a piece
of pizza like maybe you're freaking out
you know like maybe you need to regulate
maybe maybe someone needs to hug you
maybe you need a weighted blanket maybe
you need to sit down maybe you need to
shut your eyes like that's a little
cleaning up I love my weighted blank
buddy get real I'm under a student as
soon as Leela goes down uh Daddy's under
that weighted blanket because it because
that's why in this story I kept going
who's holding you who's touching you
um like that that [__] matters and you
want to talk about distance between us
you know like I'm all right we've had
dinner before you and I and run into
each other but we do the human thing we
do the first class coach thing we do the
how's your tour thing and as you're
telling me this story my heart starts to
crack open and you just wanna
we're out of [__] Space Rock and hold
each other and we're in these beautiful
but delicate
me I don't want to say meat suits that's
too crude but we're in these these
bodies and whoa the fact that any of us
are
fighting or arguing or it's ridiculous
or cruel or Petty it's a it's a joke
it's a it's a bad joke we need to be
United in our suffering
like imagine running for office and
being like
look I've been through some stuff I know
you've been through some stuff why can't
we just be United in all the awful stuff
we've experienced in our lives because
because I've lost you know a parent and
I I have a daughter who who his had
cancer three times and and and we deal
with all and then I have her her brother
who who you know needs needs care as
well and and and uh and we're just
trying to figure this thing out and man
what what's going on in your life like
like did you lose your job are you
divorced like you know do you have a
disability yeah this this this this this
I'm not even interrupting I just it's
not sure yeah
instead of doing what we do which is
hiding our suffering and acting like
it's an error uh I'm all for you know I
don't that might be getting too ahead of
ourselves it's like
it's a bridge that that's the kind of
person I am it's like show me yours uh
show me your suffering I'll show you my
suffering there's a Mary Oliver poem
where she says that it's like I believe
it's wild geese it is wild geese and
that is
not the thing to turn away from it's the
glue it's the closeness it as you I
heard you say in another interview it
removes that last bit of daylight
between you and your brothers in the
band yeah
that's that's a great forage together by
the fire you know that we experience and
but we were divided by all the
as I I've been uh doing a lot of reading
and studying about the concert for
Bangladesh and George Harrison would say
that the tidal wave of [__] and we
are all just like call you know beneath
the tidal wave of [__] when when the
truth is that that the things that unite
us are and I had such a it's become such
a cliche but the things that unite us
are greater and more important than the
things that divide us and Messier and
stickier and uglier and embarrassed and
that that's why I was like how were you
in the car because I people grieving
people in shock people for weeks I just
would SOB I just sobbed and every uh
chaplain that would walk in I'd be like
let's pray you know every person will
like let's pray pray with me and and I
would uh my wife's um I don't want to
get ahead here let me just tell you this
this is this is the important thing
after my wife and I at that moment we
look in each other's eyes and all these
family and friends had gathered to be
with us in our moment of suffering and
they're all worried about alley and I
walk in the waiting room
and without thinking
and this I wasn't this guy before this
moment I said
can we pray
and we all held hands
and I prayed to Jesus Christ
and that was
like you know it was raised Catholic and
you know I but when I beat my later
teenage years I you know was like I'm
Buddhist man or I'm this or I'm that or
I'm I'm like let me make a religion that
gives me the lifestyle that I would like
to live and I can just make money let me
make my own you know like let me take
this from here and this from here
whatever but um but this was like my
moment of coming to Faith and it was it
was almost like there's that famous
Abraham Lincoln quote that I'll probably
Butcher and it may be apocryphal but he
said I've found myself on my knees many
times because I had nowhere else to go
and it was just this moment of of
something deep inside of me wanted to
pray to God and needed God and needs God
and so from there on out
um we were early and Hallie was you know
it was kind of thing where okay so the
surgeon after you know and this is like
probably two hours after that so she's
probably in surgery for six to eight
hours and we get you know LED down this
like I always say it was like a
kubrick-esque hallway you know in the
hospital to a a darkened
um prep room like where like on Monday
morning for this was a Sunday night so
it was like ha it was like some couple
fluorescent fluorescent lights on
um the rest of it was completely dark uh
a lot of Bays where you have like the
curtains that would be drawn but they
were all oh all the curtains were open
there were very few gurneys in there
and it was like just a big empty room
half lit big empty room and the surgeon
you know pulled up a chair and had to
sit down and
and I you know he's like you know so I
cut into her head and all this stuff
started coming out and it was a tumor
really syrupy tumor and it was um I
think I got 90 of it
um but she had Strokes uh and of course
I said is she gonna make it okay like
that thing you learned from watching
hospital dramas your whole life you know
yeah and he said I don't know
he said I don't know and so it became
evident
um in fact the next day you know here
she is in the now she's sedated she's on
Fentanyl and everything else and uh
she's completely her head's covered and
her face is covered and she's intubated
she's got the ventilator in and he comes
by like four o'clock the next afternoon
you know before he's about to leave and
he said you know if you told me this
time yesterday we'd be here I'd say
okay it's good
you know this is a good place to be
right now with this yeah but it was
always it became and then as the
pathology came in and it was like this
they thought it was an ependymoma with a
high grade ependymoma and it just really
deadly
brain tumor that keeps coming back just
keeps coming back and we know children
who've passed from from these tumors
um
and at that point it was like well if
she survives the trauma of The Strokes
and the the traumatic brain injury she
suffered when she came in here
she probably won't survive the cancer
you know so we got to the point where we
were like
man let's get through this part so we
can fight the cancer like fighting the
cancer seemed like a good goal the
reward yeah the manageable thing yeah
yeah the yeah the structure that was our
our life became so unstructured
and like any sense of routine or
um uh cohesion was ripped away from us
right that the idea of being on going
through chemo or radiation that was a
routine
yeah it's like a war instead of uh I'm
not trying to be funny but like it's
almost like Frogger it's like you get
hit by something coming or a war like a
war now we can have a situation room we
can plan in this we can not strategize
talk to different experts not just
crossing a crazy Highway yeah and so
every every hour it came to breaking
down the days to hours to minutes and my
wife's old boss brought um their very
Catholic Family and he and his wife
brought us
um these like Catholic prayer books
right and
uh the avid's sister Bonnie her who now
plays piano with us in the band
um her husband Nick Rini uh gave me his
grandfather's rosary
and he said that his in a little note in
there and it said um that his
grandfather was this like big strong
Italian guy and uh he was afraid of
flying
and one time in his life he was on a
plane sitting next to a nun
and she gave him these rosaries and he
was never afraid again
and so so we so I began to pray the
rosary like four times a day in which
one which prayer
well I would if you go through the book
it there's like the like the hours it's
like the hours right so it's the the
um part of the Liturgy you go through
the weeks you know it's like the
different
um sufferings of Jesus the different
what do they call them
um but so it's like Cycles no the
passion is like the the you know the
walk
um to his death
yeah but they are called
uh can we get a can we get research on
this
um but so you'll you'll pray like you'll
pray the finding him in the finding him
in the temple like that's one scene
um uh the Immaculate Conception is
another one where Mary meets with uh
Anna
John the Baptist's mother
and Saint Anne and that's that sounds
extra biblical to me is that in the
Bible are you saying it's apocryphal no
it's not it is not an it is not a it is
not it is not not in the Bible
it is not not in the Bible you're saying
it is in the Bible it is in the Bible
yes uh it's in Luke
um John the Baptist
um there was a connection between John
the Baptist
mother and Mary and his mother was much
older
and um they both got pregnant roughly
around the same time
okay okay yeah
it's it you know I think about this this
it's like no atheists in foxholes
obviously right right
um Abraham Lincoln now Bob Crawford
you're in the situation
um where to to use your words kind of if
I was in that situation I would be
throwing up wholehearted old school dear
Jesus or heavenly father or in Jesus
name amen all these different things
that's that's what you do
um that's what you have to do right I
mean there's no there's no
there's no just floating around being
like reality is a mystery you you go
straight to Mercy you go straight to
petitioning right and and pleading right
right after all this I'm wondering what
your relationship to prayer is now I I
know there are studies that prayer helps
there's like blind Studies have you
heard about these where I've heard but I
haven't delved into them I can tell you
from my personal experience
is when things are going well excuse me
uh it's hard to pray right like the the
most important thing of a chestnut right
there yeah it's true
um
I talked to someone
a year after all when when things kind
of like I left the band for a year and
um
you know it was just because how I went
through treatment and and um and I came
back and then that was that next year
was hard right to be on stage
celebrating and stuff and and like talk
you mentioned pant talking about pants
like I'd be on the bus and these guys
are talking about jeans 100 jeans or
whatever 200 I don't know what whatever
and I was like
at first for a while I was like oh I was
so much better when you woke up you you
can't go back right you can't go back
but when you get some normalcy routine a
couple
Good Year under your belt
you know those 200 James genes come back
like you the desire for the the comfort
of existence
privilege the privilege of being able to
talk by the way Joe and I went to that
Gene place I think
I think it's in I forget where we were
but we were in North Carolina and I have
oh Raleigh denim not sponsors yeah
that no no in fact decidedly not [__]
you Raleigh I'm just kidding wonderful
wonderful pants
um but that is that is
you were craving the normalcy it's
almost like don't let me put words in
your mouth but there's almost a jealousy
it's like must be nice to sit around
just [__] farting about jeans right
now right look [__] you know my kid
is blah blah blah blah blah yeah you're
blah blah talking about food and dinner
and restaurants and jeans what the Yeah
Yeah but then you know you like it's you
know I I imagine myself coming back and
like wearing black all the time
and just be a quiet figure you know like
yeah and I and I you know I
the it's the habit of prayer it's it's a
habit right like like what I find now is
you gotta go through periods where my
prayer life is good and I'm flexing that
muscle and I'm you know nourishing
myself just like we talked about earlier
this is the same thing with therapy it's
all it all is I ask what you mean good
it all is self care self-care
maintenance
maintenance if you're not if if you're
not flexing the prayer muscle if you
know it's not right like if you're a
person of any any faith any faith
um you don't pray shouldn't be a wish
list right
well that's what I was going to ask we
need we need a definition of terms here
when you're praying is it more
contemplative is it more silent is it
more um tell me what prayer is for you
okay so a good friend of mine who's uh
Pastor a rule he's retired past now he
he said you know sometimes like
what he'll do is he'll have an index
card and he'll write somebody's name on
it and he'll just he'll just think about
them
you know somebody he's praying for he
just thinks about them for a while
and then you know then you know ask God
you know and thanks God for this person
and ask God for for this person's needs
to be met and for the greatest prayer I
learned because I would go through the
waves of being um like as things would
happen you know how I had recurrences
and and I would get bitter right I would
get really bitter like the jeans thing
that's a great example or you know of my
bit my exhibiting my bitterness
um
and he actually said to me one day when
I was when her when she had her first
recurrence and I was like I loved God I
didn't like people
I couldn't deal with people
but I was really faithful to God which
I got bad news for me
that's not right that's not how it works
like right God created people like you
know it's almost like you're saying well
I'm better than these people
I think that's all from my theological
perspective that's like saying I like
the ocean but I don't like all these
[__] glasses of water yes sitting
around me like the animating principle
to me behind people like who you really
are for from me from my theological
perspective is the Divine indwelling you
and I are talking is Bob and Pete and
that's right but the way that I can love
you without knowing you is because I
know deep down in our core we're the
same exact thing what else really could
we be
um so that that's but I struggle with
people too so if I always say Jesus
didn't say you like your neighbor he
said love your neighbor so there's lots
of people you can be like this isn't for
me but I was raised believing that like
if you were a Christian that meant you
were to fake it and I'm not saying it's
not nice to be sweet it is nice to be
sweet I'm saying as Richard Rohr says
the word nice is nowhere in the New
Testament we've turned it something
that's just kind of kind and social and
good into the point when really the
point is for us to figure out what
exactly is the animating principle
behind you as you tell me this story and
behind me as I listen to it and and
that's that's where we can you and I can
merge even without suffering if we could
have that sort of Awakening yeah
yeah I love Richard Rohr like we we uh
we we Ava people love Richard Moore we
finally yeah great great nourishment in
his uh in in his in him in him yeah yeah
the the prayer that um that this yeah
you were saying about prayer well and
this is this is like what I what I pray
for other people
yeah he prayed for me and he said um
he said that that God meets you wherever
you are
that you can just feel the presence of
God Wherever You Are
you know in your bitterness or you know
in your pain and joy and of course I
think that's such a key part of the
Christ story is that he's in the in the
uh garden and he's like I don't want to
do this yeah but if we it's it's again
these are the moments we would whitewash
or sand blast out of the story is these
moments of Doubt or anger or fear and I
know people have different opinions on
whether or not Jesus had those things I
tend to be in the camp that he did that
he was fully a person as well as fully
Divine
um but but those that's how you just how
you and I relate over our suffering
people say that it's Jesus's
imperfection meaning his suffering that
makes him uh like nobody likes Superman
really like Superman with the bullets
bouncing off we we actually
respond and connect and bond way more to
a broken this is Richard Rohr by the way
a broken naked loser that's what he
calls Jesus a loser by social
definitions of course right all of his
friends turn their back the government
turns their back he's murdered he's
betrayed this is not but we've turned it
into the faith of winners for winning
people and uh and the hundred dollar
genes nothing wrong with all of us
having our 100 G's that's fine I'm just
saying don't don't confuse the message
it's not it's not just the Winner's
Circle in fact the whole I would say the
whole one of the one of the founding
principles of the faith is what you do
with suffering and what suffering means
and what suffering does to us yeah
yeah and you know for peop there's a lot
of people out there who who have
problems with Christianity or or the the
gospel or you know
you
gotta allow for I think people have
trouble being in the mystery
um like being the mystery
you know people there we are a very
rational Society well we don't act
rational but but we we kind of like
believe that we're so rational and we're
so evolved that you know intellectually
that that
um we can believe this or not believe
this or and if we don't believe you know
whatever I'm just like this came up this
weekend in a conversation and it's like
there's a great song by a folk singer
Iris DeMent Iris DeMent
and it's let the mystery be
and I just it's go look it up people
like it's it just it's very
reassuring and and when you go to a
Catholic Mass
and look we don't we don't go our family
doesn't go to mass like we haven't gone
anywhere since covid but I mean we we
were attending non-denominational and
that's that's probably where we belong
but my wife and I have great it's funny
my wife came to her Catholic Affinity
from the Church of Christ in North
Carolina from a completely different
place but it's like but when you go to a
Catholic mass it said like the mystery
of Faith you know like that's a a big
part of it that's right well that's
that's a Richie Roy thing too we've
turned faith into the opposite faith is
supposed to be your your comfort level
in the uncertainty and we turned it into
absolute certainty
pardon the interruption weirdos back to
the show in 60 seconds but this show is
brought To Us by our friends at Trade
coffee if you love drinking coffee every
morning like I do like Val does and who
doesn't you have to check out Trade
coffee trade makes it super easy to get
the very best coffee delivered fresh
from the finest local Roasters around
the country going to a coffee shop is a
great experience but it's not something
most of us can do every day so if you're
looking for that delicious local coffee
shop taste on a daily basis it is much
easier to do and to get it with Trade
coffee if you've been getting your
coffee from the grocery store and
drinking the same coffee every day I
mean mix it up guys mix it up it's time
to try something even better with trade
Trade coffee makes it so easy to get
fresh roasts delivered to your doorstep
from local Roasters around the country
they are a coffee subscription service
if you haven't put that together that
makes it so simple for you you to
discover new coffees and make your best
cup of coffee at home every day no fancy
equipment required trade partners with
some of the nation's top rated
independent Roasters to send you coffee
that they know you'll love fresh to your
home and on your preferred schedule and
you get to support small local
businesses that my friends is what we
call a win-win whether you already know
that what you like or you're new to
Specialty coffee and need some help
trade makes it easy and convenient to
discover new coffees they'll send you
ground coffee or whole beans for however
you make your coffee at home so whether
or not you're just getting started or
you are a coffee Aficionado looking to
to discover something new trade
guarantees you'll love your first bag or
they'll send you a new one for free we
like to do the whole bean because we
like to experiment with the different
types of grind to get the course for the
French press for the fun you do it
different ways but it's just so fun to
know that you can introduce some novelty
some freshness something exciting and
support local businesses while drinking
the best coffee you've ever had in your
life so upgrade your coffee today with
Trade coffee and let them take the
guesswork out of finding your perfect
cup right now trade is offering our
listeners a total of thirty dollars off
your subscription plus free shipping at
drinktrade.com weird that's
drinktrade.com weird for thirty dollars
off your subscription to the best
coffees in the country drinktrade.com
weird alright everybody let's get back
to the show
let's pick back up here yeah I was
excited so I just went pee and this
conversation man I just want to say it
just gave me one of these like peas
where my feet were on the ground does
that make sense like I was walking I I
just meant it made me it's making me
more present the the the Gratitude uh
for life and for the present and for and
to think of beautiful things like people
praying for people on note cards yeah
sometimes that's the most overwhelming
thing I've seen you guys play many times
and I'm not trying to shift to that so
let's talk about the evidence I'm just
saying one of the things that's
beautiful about the Avid show is you're
like wow every person here could be
punching someone in the face but instead
they're singing and dancing and crying
and and and pointing their awareness
towards the same beautiful things almost
talk about a mystery like that like
there's a like for me you know it's like
we started out and it was you know we
were all much younger and you know we
were in a band and and all this like the
the young man band dreams were still in
play of like being in a band and it's
just it's what you always wanted to do
since you were a teenager and you know
you're doing it and and at some point
not too far in it you had people who
were our age but bringing their parents
you know and then those people brought
their kids and then that's when it began
to just a few years into it it just
began to occur to me like this is
unusual like in the best possible way
and and there is like Scott and Seth
they write incredible lyrics and they're
beautiful and they're meaningful people
attach great meaning to them for their
own lives and that's that's what makes
music so spiritual like music is the
great universal language yeah the it's
the ancient you know like if you imagine
like hitting uh uh tapping uh um was it
a gong or a bell that just rings and it
you know people do all the time to clear
their minds and to pray and this and
that but like
like that's it's the Mystic chord of
life right you talk about Leonard Cohen
uh um and and
Beyond
Scott and says
um their intentions with all their
lyrics is honest and pure and genuine
that's why the Avett Brothers that's why
the experience of coming to a show is
what it is that's why the music is what
it is because it's honest and raw and
genuine but I believe there is also a
mystery associated with it like there's
something you know like church
you know like church are you crazy yeah
you can go to see Bruce Springsteen and
that's like church too yeah you know you
know but but I mean there there is a
there's a mystery like why is music why
does Music touch us the way it does all
of us yeah somewhere deep inside this is
why I believe like there are things that
confirm faith for me right and accepting
I I first I accept the mystery
premise like you if you can figure it
out
you haven't figured it out like
particularly with God God faith like if
if I told you I knew exactly the deal
with God yeah
um I'm full of [__] like I'm I'm lying
to you because you're selling me
something I'm selling you something
because I know that this is bigger than
me
and I think that music is connected
somewhere
with all of that that it's it's just
amazing that someone can play
that someone who does I don't speak the
same language to or I can't understand
can play an instrument and it can touch
my soul and it can touch the soul of
every
person on the planet yeah that's right
and it but it's greater than the sum of
its parts and I I don't know if you read
Richie Richard Roy's book on the Trinity
but God is relationship itself right why
why is it the the Triune God it's
because God he says God is more of a
verb than a noun and it's and it's built
in relationship and people who listen to
this podcast know I say this all the
time so when I said are you kidding me I
just couldn't be agreeing more
um that an Avett Brothers auris bring
scene show or a Green Day show it can be
like church in this beautiful way where
the perform the the instruments blend
first and foremost right the Rhythm
Section which is like the heartbeat
blends with the bass which is like the
roots blends with the the violin or the
fiddle which is like the spirit and then
the human voice there's something
there's something literally in in the
creation story about the breath coming
out and and then now ideas which are
objects that we create with our mind are
being implanted and we're all having the
same idea at the same time so all of the
members merge with their instruments all
those instruments and members become
something we call a band they put on
something we call a show and then the
show merges with the audience the the
audience also is individuals that merge
into one thing right called an audience
and the best shows I know you know this
feeling are when the band and the
audience merge into one well that's
absolutely a key right the the the the
the audience sends the energy to the
band the band sends receives that and
sends the energy back to the audience
then the audience sends it back to the
band and it's this a concert is a
constant like because the audience I
think the audience touches like starts
they light the light the fuse because
they're there
anticipating this experience that
they're about to have and then so
they're cheering because when before the
band comes on and I I've been in the
audience like before I played in a band
like going to concerts was was my thing
you know I I went to many concerts and
and so you're so excited for the band to
come on and so you're cheering right
before the you know when the the tech
comes on and you know the Tunes the bass
or the guitar and that just amps up the
crowd more and more and more and then
the band so you're you send out the love
and then the band comes out and then
there's this like Mutual greeting and
then the man starts playing the song and
they're sending yeah we hear you with
the love here's here take this take some
more of this and then like that it just
that's how the night goes and that is
what was a room full or a stadium full
of strangers becomes an Avett Brothers
concert and that that's a transformation
of sorts I'll tell you one let me say
one more thing on this uh sure sorry to
interrupt you but the most amazing
moment for me on stage
is when we are doing a song well maybe
it's just you know Scott or Seth doing a
solo song Maybe it's three of us up
there doing a song it's a very quiet
song
and it's you know there's like Miles
Davis would talk about the space between
the music right you know uh when it's
that moment in the song where it's
absolutely quiet where the there's a
break in the music
and then the audience is absolutely
quiet hushed and it's that moment of
just like silence in the middle of this
whole thing
like that is just the most incredible
like that's the loudest noise it's just
great
The Emptiness yes because
I think what a lot of us are looking for
whether we're going to see the top gun
or going to see you could call it or see
you guys play you could call it escapism
[Music]
um that would be putting it down I think
I think at a concert let's say what
you're escaping is your story which is
constantly changing so it's not the
realest part of you but in that silence
just for a moment that which is
essential to all of us and shared in all
of us gets to be quiet loud including
you guys right I mean that Stillness is
a whole Space w-h-o-l-e it's a whole
Space instead of the noise of of even
you and I talking right now we're
telling our stories and maybe you relate
maybe you don't relate but it's these
moments in between where it's like it's
the white part on the page that that's
where we all are or Scott would say in
in uh in terms of Fine Art and paintings
negative space
yeah the need for negative space that's
it so let's talk a little bit about your
theology i i blabbed a little bit about
the ocean and the glasses of water that
sort of leans towards my
um I don't even want to talk more about
mine I'm interested in where you are in
that faith and and we've talked a little
bit about how suffering ignited it how
suffering and riches it how here's
another Richard Rohr human beings don't
change unless things stop going their
way I mean why would you change if
things are going your way he actually
prays for one humiliation a day
um I I've sort of stagnated I haven't
been reading
um my spiritual text and stuff this is
going to sound like a joke I had like a
weird call with my mother this weekend
and I was like
perfect because it was uncomfortable it
was like this uncomfortable chat I hung
up the phone and I was reading about
suffering and I had I had something to
latch into I had a a feeling that could
um you said light the fuse light the
fuse on the idea otherwise it's just
sort of and God's sad the thoughts but
when we're hurting it kind of makes it
stickier and we're ready to know
everything right we're ready we're like
we're we got the ears on like we're it
humbles us it opens us right we got the
ears on is beautiful I love that so why
don't you tell me just a little bit
about it what are what are some of the
things the mystery of it when I went PP
I was going to tell you
um God is the name of the blanket we put
over the mystery to give it shape which
is one of my favorite quotes that it's
not about
certainty that's what the ego wants I
want to know what God is so then I can
tell you that you're wrong and we're
right we're in and you're out and all
that sort of stuff that's an ego trip
but when I say that God the reason I
believe in God hold on to God you play
with God is because God as an idea as a
as a as a symbol as a metaphor is my way
of participating with the mystery it's
my way of giving it a shake with the
blanket right um so let's start there
old man in the sky fine if you do have
an old man in the sky tell me tell me
the images tell me the the quotes tell
me the the ways that you land on this
thing that is so nebulous that so many
people just turn away from it
yeah well I think that the ultimate
right like I think when I pass
um to get I'll just jump right to we
know
Cloud world where you're playing ping
pong table with your grandfather who
looks exactly like he looked at the day
he passed away yeah you know I I do love
that idea I do love that idea but um I
think it's uh I think it's you you you
go to God because you become
United with that energy
yeah you know you become United and it
and it but it feels like that like it
feels like all the love that you've felt
in your life and everyone that you've
loved and all the people that loved you
you you do see them because you are
you're all merged
right yeah no I like that I the more I
study and even the further out things I
do the more I'm like the traditional
understanding of Heaven ping pong with
your grandpa
I would take issue with that being
literally true I'm saying but like
that's what you kind of think at one
point that's what I thought no of course
but George Harrison says this too in the
documentary The two-part documentary
he's like
the further you go you you start this
journey away from old man in the sky
ping pong with Grandpa who looks exactly
like he did and then by the time you're
through the Journey you've come full
circle and realized that it all of it is
true and all of it is not true meaning
in my from my perspective uh the
afterlife having the merging into the
essence of all potential
means the essence of all potential
meaning that too meaning that to meaning
that too I've even had some psychedelic
experiences where I'm like were you Bob
there
no but yes you were there it's like
Dorothy waking up you were a part of
that because I went into the all
everything was there every cat's whisker
that's ever been born was there and at
the same time did I see a single cat no
not not literally but the metaphor of
cloud city every cat and Bob's there
works pretty good for our limited
constricted brain yeah well and as I
don't know if Harrison said this in the
in the documentary that you're referring
to but I believe there's a on YouTube
there's a 1997 interview on VH1
and he man I can't believe it's on VH1
because he is just talking some serious
truth and he says um you know we're
playing roles like you know right now
you're whoever and I'm I'm George and
you're whoever but but we're all just
we're all just the same we're all yeah
right now at this moment where these are
our masks and and these are the roles
we're playing and that's right my
personal you know you talk about Richard
Rohr uh a lecture and I don't think it's
a book it's a lecture that has been
really
um important to me is true self false
self
okay so you're the first you're the
first guest to bring it up before I did
I've listened to true self fall self
through all the way through three times
I I'm obsessed with it I always go back
to it when I'm right when I'm feeling it
and it is like that like
um James Finley
uh James Finley who is is in New Mexico
with
the center
okay for action and contemplation um and
Scott told me he said this he said that
uh you just really really need to read
one book
if you have a book that speaks to you
you just read that one over and over
again
and like and that's that's kind of like
it's good to go back to that on a yearly
basis true self I agree I feel that way
about that one and power of now but yes
absolutely you mean but it's an audio
it's not for people interested it's on
Audible yeah it's also an audible okay I
believe that's where I have it okay and
it seems to be a lecture like a weekend
retreat it is yeah yeah yeah it's not a
book yeah and the deeper you get you
know you read some Richard Rohr books
then you realize that you know he's
talking about Thomas Merton like he's
really connected to what Thomas Merton
was was thinking and his thinking so
then you know you listen there's there's
great
um
lectures Thomas Merton taught at
Gethsemane which is a a monastery I
guess in Kentucky
and you can on Audible as well you can
find his like his teach he's teaching
the Young
what do you call them abbots monks I
don't know I don't know wait there's an
audio of him it's teaching oh a lot of
them yeah yeah really I didn't know that
yeah he's got photographs of presidents
and and Merton teaching ideas yes yes so
they're really great but but um sorry no
no just by far and if you said well what
is the and I like yeah man he's got he's
getting a hard time on Twitter this guy
Tim Keller who I love and I still love
and I don't know why he gets a hard time
you know he gets really harassed on
Twitter these days
um and I don't spend too much time
investigating why because because he
means a lot to me his sermons I listen
to his and you can also on iTunes listen
to his sermons it's gospel in life
um maybe more conservative
uh maybe a little more traditional than
Richard Rohr in a lot of ways but um but
intellectually
uh he he can explain the faith to a
non-believer I think better than than
anyone else really
wow and I I found great comfort in his
sermons
uh great and these are true self false
so the essence of true self which we
sort of hinted at with George Harrison
is that you are for lack of a better
word and that this all of this is for
lack of a better word the Dao that can
be named is not the real Dao
you are your awareness you are not your
thoughts you are the witnessing presence
that's observing your thoughts and
around those thoughts you've built a
Persona you call yours Bob I call it
right Pete
um but like if we lived forever and I
took you Bob to another planet and on
that planet something about the
atmosphere changed your body into a blob
a blob of blue goo and we started
calling the Baba blue goo funny that
it's a bob of blue goo blob of blue goo
if we started calling that blob
um Harriet uh and and you live for six
million years on this other planet
because you don't die on this planet at
certainly after maybe a thousand years
you would completely forget that you
ever were Bob Crawford on the planet
Earth so what the point of that thought
experiment is the witnessing presence
that is kind of taking the amalgamation
of the thing that you call yourself this
construct your history your past well
I'm a musician I played in this band I
I'm a southern person all that I like
this I like that well now you're a
[__] blob dude you know and yet same
blob different day that's right there
you go and the essence the animating
principle of that blob is the same thing
that animated Bob so what you are isn't
what you think you are the Buddhists say
they have two things they go who am I
which is a great thing to sit and say
who am I and we're not talking about I'm
Bob I'm from the south I'm saying who am
I when you say I what do I mean and then
they follow that up with who's asking
which is just if the first one doesn't
bake your noodle which it doesn't for a
lot of people because you'll go I'm Pete
I'm a six foot six Lithuanian you have
all these answers you go who's asking
who's asking in that quiet weird echoey
dark staticky filled khaki Sandstorm
behind your eyes you say who Am I who is
asking who's asking that's it that's the
whole that's true self also so
Richard says Richard Rohr says the
primary folk the point of spirituality
of religion is to get you to identify
and get you in relationship to your true
self to to know who you are we would say
in Christian language in God who you are
in God
um by the way which is the point of
almost every fairy tale including Harry
Potter I like to point out Harry Potter
is from special blood Royal Blood that's
all the story that you're from something
greater and something mysterious
something way bigger than your sad
British family you're from Hogwarts why
do we tell that story over and over and
over it's because it's your story it's
everybody's story is what Merton and
Rohr and all these people are trying to
say is wake up you're not Harry Potter
the the dweebie thing your Harry Potter
The Wizard and you have a Birthright
that's beloved you are the Beloved yes
and it's better than laser beams and
Patronus constructo it's your beloved
you belong
your trust of God is
well let me put it to this I I would say
because who you are deep down is is
divine
I would say when you die you're you're
actually going in rather than going out
you're going it was there the whole time
I think you and I will go when we're
when we're there we'll go it was there
the whole time and I I don't know if
we'll actually be there as separate
entities but we will realize it will
have been there the whole time does that
jive with you yeah yeah that does it
does yeah it's more of a falling away
than uh yeah uh uh coming to I guess is
the way right thinking about Henry now
and have you ever read Henry nowin no a
lot of names he was a great um
was he Catholic I don't know if he was
Catholic but um
he spent a lot of time working with
special needs individuals but um he has
a sermon he talks about the Beloved and
it's the you know it's like that moment
where Jesus is baptized uh by John and
the dove comes and lands you know on his
head and God says you are my beloved
um and that's who we all we are all the
Beloved we are all you know so we are
all chosen by God like we're already
chosen by God that was that's a big
Richard thing is that I grew up in a
church that worshiped nothing wrong with
worshiping but like worship Jesus
instead of realizing that he was uh
demonstrating he was modeling what a
human life is to be and we're all to
wake up in this life not not just later
but now that's a Richard Rohr thing too
he goes it's Heaven all the way to
heaven that that you're supposed to have
this realization here and now and
there's no other time to have it but
here and now and now of course everybody
knows I'm going to bring this up The
Prodigal Son which as I always say is
Jesus's closer it's the most agreed upon
if what are you guys what's your second
Encore these days oh oh you know um uh
well we oh no hard feelings every night
no heart wow that's our prodigal son
looking out that's it yes that's right
that song is it's just if you guys
haven't heard no hard feelings that's
exactly what we're talking about it's it
even addresses the infinite potentials
that it is running into Jesus in this
guy and it is going into a snow or a
rainstorm it's all of that
um it's just a masterpiece of a song
um but the prodigal son Jesus is closer
to me it's like you you're always with
me in everything I have is yours that's
the punch line so the father is the
stand-in for God it's just the son who
thinks he's a fuck-up he says no matter
what you're doing I was there the whole
time we were we were never separate we
can't be separate the whole thing was
just a a ruse anyway let's have a party
you know that that's one of um Scott
produced a song about Roger Ebert's last
words have you heard that song I Don't
Know
it's all an elaborate hoax those were
Roger Ebert's last words
so but he said it with joy yeah this
this is the realization of the true self
there's a there's a laying down of a
burden when you go it's a hoax there's a
sad scary way to say this was a hoax
there's also beautiful that's what my
daughter's name means by the way Leela
means the play of the universe you could
say the hoax of the Universe I like
player the dance but it's a way of
saying like Bob to you right now I'm
saying it's it's a Leela it's a Leela
it's all for its own sake it's all for
its own Evolution and growth and play
and dance and exploration and and look
at all of the things that that grow it's
the Buddhist thing the the lotus flower
grows in the in the mud you know what I
mean yeah that's the birth the death the
resurrection that we're in but the human
ego just wants growth it's like
corporations we just want growth we just
want winning and then we have to keep
winning like and how can you just keep
winning you can't keep winning you can't
that's right
that's that's the whole thing and that's
why the the mascot for the Christian
faith is nailed to a cross that's the
whole point is like look at it there has
to be a different game being played it
can't just be does Bob Crawford win does
Bob have a gold toilet does Pete have a
gold toilet get the I you know when we
were shooting crashing we would
sometimes shoot in like 11 million
dollar Penthouse Apartments and I was
like buddy everybody's pooping
everybody's sleeping everybody's eating
everybody's watching TV everybody for
the most part yeah what I'm saying is it
ain't there it's one of my favorite
Jesus like don't lay up your treasure
where where moth and dust and rust can
corrupt it get better treasure otherwise
you just have a seventy thousand dollar
TV Dude like
congratulations like like not see you in
hell but like you're still on fire right
you're still on fire I don't mean
Hellfire I mean it's still written on
running water it's nowhere it's nothing
and it's nowhere so there needs to be a
a deeper Dimension and that's what
spirituality has offered me yeah
well this is like we to continue the
Richard Rohr line of thinking is falling
upward
and the idea that that the first part of
life you know it's about achieving
collecting
and uh and getting comfortable and then
the second part of building a container
building a container second part of life
is about getting rid of it all and
shedding it and forgetting it
and putting it aside I talked to someone
to get back to my daughter for a moment
because I think this is really relevant
actually was getting my hair cut today
and the guy that was cutting my hair he
has his sister's special needs and so we
connected on that and I said you know
and he was also kind of revealed to me
his faith
and um I said you know when
like we you and I you know we're always
trying to achieve like we're we're just
like from an early age you gotta get
good grades and you gotta be a success
and you gotta make money and you gotta
you know buy a nice car or buy a house
or and you're just completely even even
now it's like I want to do this podcast
and I'm gonna do this thing with
SiriusXM I'm gonna do them what we're
gonna record a record and I just want to
do I want to do I want to be I want to
be
my daughter she's in a wheelchair she
doesn't use her left hand you know she
her her her success is existing
with living like like she did the most
she's achieved the most badass thing you
could imagine she survived three brain
tumors
and she's got the scars to prove it and
and she's
like our egos me you know your ego my
ego
um
she's free of that
I mean she's not it's not that she
doesn't have an ego no I understand she
does but that that life goal of being
and doing
like she doesn't have that burden you
know she she she's you can 12 12 years
old she's you know she more like a she's
in Prince she'll be in princesses
forever
you know okay and you know God willing
but but she feels music just like so
intensely and she's so joyful and so
happy not all the time most of the time
um yes
and uh so she teaches me right of course
because if if I want if I think about
Hallie the Hallie I want
I'm I'm gonna be angry and bitter
and forever and I'm gonna burden her
right but if I can
get get into Hallie's world and see the
world the way she sees it that's a good
place to be that's like that's the place
to be right and I this is attention
right because no matter how much you're
like I accept what has happened and I
accept her as she is there are times
when you're just like Halle would you
get in that Stander can we get can we
like you know do we need to put your arm
in a cast to straighten out your left
wrist and you know all these things that
we do to her
um uh and we just and then you know we
want her to learn and we want her to be
all she can be but but also
accepting who she is and seeing
ourselves in that
seeing it as being again you know a gift
a gift right she's the gift she's the
teacher yeah Bobby you're a delicious
sandwich one last thing one one last
bite oh I'm not rapping on this I'll go
on this on this I just want to call you
a delicious family before but before I I
forget uh hopefully with spicy mustard
too I love of course Golden's kids
mustard um oh my God uh when you know my
my wife like I'm gone a lot and my wife
is doing a lot of the bathing like the
work of Hallie is is getting her in the
bath getting her out of the bath getting
her dressed giving her medicine she
doesn't sleep like she needs to be
turned you and I we like turn ourselves
over at night how many we don't even
know how many times
she'll get into a position and call out
because she needs you to put her back in
the place that she wants to be so
it is a very physically demanding uh you
know caregiving it's very physically
demanding but but the nights that I'm
getting her dressed you know
um
I'm putting on her socks putting our PJs
and I have had this thought many times
and I've had it like where like you want
to we can talk about reading Richard
Rohr or reading scripture
um but but when do we experience God
like when are we when are we feeling it
like like that's the that's the mystery
right like like we want to get to where
we're feeling it because I can talk to
you about the prodigal son and what I
learned about Luke uh you know chapter
two or chapter four and then I can go
out and get in line at Starbucks and
curse somebody out for whatever you know
you know what I'm saying like I can have
these like human course really frail
ugly human moment I'm very capable of
those as much as of course yes but when
you feel God and one of the times that I
feel God have felt God repeatedly is
like getting her dressed it's like you
know she can't get herself dressed and
so it's like this is caregiving right
and I think man this is what God wants
us to do like this is it right here this
is how he wants us to love each other
like to care for each other like the
idea of like you know just like I think
people feel this like with elderly
parents more than with their children
you know you get your kids to the age
when they can dress themselves and that
part of it for you is done I think
there's plenty of work to do but that
part's done but but a lot of people get
to where they have an elderly parent and
then they're getting that person dressed
or getting cleaning up that person
you know changing that person's diaper
and you know we experience this with our
daughter on a daily basis and
and it's not lost on me and I'm sure on
my wife that that this is this is what
God this is a beautiful thing to do like
I wish I didn't have to do it like I
wish this wasn't the reality but but I
think you know it being the reality you
know there's something sacred about it
yeah and you I'll uh see beautiful
sandwich with spicy mustard so
it's in taoism uh or it might be Chinese
then but I'm pretty sure it's taoism um
although it references the devil yeah
the great way so merging with God
is not difficult for those who have no
preferences
so the Bob who isn't thinking about the
life he wanted or this or the way it
could have been who's just doing what's
happening you you merge into what
Christians would call the Kingdom of
Heaven what they would call the Dao uh
God is within you kingdom of God exactly
precisely Richard also he talks about
that he's like this is a big thing in
the in the west is we think conversion
is an intellectual experience that you
and I can like talk our way there but
really it's always an accident it's
always you changing a child that may not
want to be changed or bathing a child
that's getting heavier every year or
whatever it may be the the joke is we
practice to become as accident prone as
possible I love that line but my
favorite and everybody knows I'm going
to say this because it's my favorite
Bible verses and I always say it in the
King James I don't know why but lest ye
become as little children he shall not
enter the kingdom of heaven or the
kingdom of God which which we mean here
and now so of course
I I felt that way about my I still feel
that way about my daughter she's
splashing in the tub
she's right
she's she's with a a slippery bubbly
warm fluid substance that none of us
understand you or and I are no closer to
understanding water just because I know
it's two hydrogen molecules and one
oxygen molecule that means dick that
that means a lot if you and I are trying
to recreate it in a lab and build
something I understand it has its value
but I mean in the big picture that is a
mystery that is a swarm of atoms and we
don't understand what's going on and and
and
she is right to play in it and your
daughter is right and these teachings
are so precious but you know us us grown
men would rather sit around and talk
about the truth when the truth is always
so much more naked so much sillier more
playful more vulnerable
um all of the things then it's not neat
in the container that's what this that's
what why I went and had a nice present p
is because you reminded me that like
it's outside the lines as much as we
want to think
we know what's going on today is Monday
and it's 20 22 and all that stuff
it's it's outside the lines and and the
profound truth is always going to hit us
from the side when we're least expecting
it because I've had those 4 a.m rocking
Leela and I'm like oh oh wow here it is
and it always happens when I stop
fighting it yeah because you can be like
uh oh I just want to go to bed well
Holly why don't you gotta sleep or you
know oh gosh she keeps getting up and
I've had those moments I've had those
moments of course you have the you know
like thank you God thank you this is
beautiful she's beautiful well
buddy sorry I have to my biggest life
hack is saying yes thank you everyone
knows I say this all the time but
Leela's been sleeping kind of rough
lately and we've been getting up in the
middle of the night I got up in the
middle of the night last night and I
I've gotten pretty good I'll say yes
thank you before I'm even out of the bed
like it's become a habit and your brain
has no idea what to do with that it
completely shifts you uh to thank thank
everything or God for what's happening
and your brain just goes like well [__]
I was going to get all worked up you you
asked me where prayer is where I am now
in my prayer life right because that
that Ebbs and flows right and I noticed
past week I was on tour last week and
and I was nowhere in my prayer life like
I take all these like theology books or
like little prayer books the
catholically I still have these Catholic
prayer and I take them and sometimes I
don't crack them you know I don't look
at them of course and uh but one thing
I've been really good at is at some
point in the day just when it strikes me
I was like Jesus I trust in you
to myself I say that I repeat that like
almost like a mantra in order if I'm
stressed out or if I'm worried or if I
have a troubled thought
um
or if I feel little if I feel small if
I've done something or said something
that man when I say that why'd I do that
I'd say just Jesus I trust in you
and that's that's a prayer
hmm and that's a grounding and Powerful
one that transforms you in real time
that that's exactly right yes thank you
as a prayer and it's the prayer I say
the most why because
I I do affirmations in the morning I
write them out and I write I trust the
flow
I trust God I trust myself but I put
capital S self and there's a real it's
not ego it's not going I'm gone because
I'm not running the show but when you
realize who you are deepest deepest deep
as is God you're like
trusting all of this even trusting your
own death is trusting yourself like who
you really are is at the center of all
of this that takes away all of that
Freudian Angry Dad drunk dad God who
can't wait to hit you with a belt
because you're a bad boy all of that
psychology gets mixed up and this is
Richard too we end up making a God that
looks like us instead of a god instead
of the other way around we should be
trying to look like God which is what
diverse self-sustaining yes ending
nurturing growing spread you know all of
that stuff that you see in nature and we
make it like our drunk dads and he can't
blame us it's such a heavy wound well
that's that just goes along with this
idea that that um
well you know we we could have if like I
just we could have had started a game
like every time
you know every time we say George
Harrison you eat a cookie or do a shot
or something like that because
um again in one of these interviews I I
saw George Harrison says like uh why
aren't we talking about death
why aren't we practicing death
we don't want to talk about it nobody
wants to talk about it and it's like
that's the the idea of like that those
affirmations you make in the morning
and or the prayer I I say in the middle
of the day if we can make those
meaningful Habits Like not you know some
sometimes you just got to go through it
I think I think the goal that I'd like
to get to is where my prayer habit is
almost
um it's second nature and it's like
brushing your teeth right because I
would like I I slip and you lose that
maintenance I think you part of it is
building up this muscle memory so when
when the [__] goes down you've got
something that's right go you got
somewhere to go that that's familiar you
know and um I think how like if we take
that we talked about being present being
like the key in in surviving tragedy or
experiencing Joy being present is the
key if you're present you're gonna
you're gonna enjoy the ping pong game
and and you're going to be able to to
deal with getting receiving the worst
news of your life you know if you can be
present and and you will be death will
be okay
yeah yeah that's right that's right it's
it's uh
I'm looking at room dust right now he's
on my desk uh not not in the astral
plane there's a picture of him
but the denial of death he talks about
when you stop denying death it frees up
all that unconscious energy that you
were using to push it away and it allows
you and imbues the present moment with
all of this joy that other would have
been otherwise would have been used to
suppress these inevitable things it's
not an error it's it's not a it's not a
mistake it's it's it's what we're here
to do it's it's what we're Light Dark
Life Death all this stuff it's all
happening it's all beautiful let's let's
get you out of here because I've taken a
lot of your time but with a couple fun
questions are you okay with that yeah oh
absolutely
um great
um I I also want to say Ben I I really
needed this I needed this chat today no
not every day is am I in the mood in
this like we were saying this one fed me
so I'm really glad that we had this time
today thank you for inviting me of
course
um have you ever almost died
yeah oh yeah yeah I um
[Music]
yeah I was in a car accident when I was
young and somebody was driving and
flipped the car and it spun on the hood
but we were all unscathed
what what do you remember of it did you
were you I remember all the time yeah I
remember trying to tell the person to
slow down and I remember the car turning
I remember all of it
wow and I remember being in the the car
with it spinning on the hood and I
remember us you know being okay
wow yeah and then they were probably
with the guy driving
no no no was it over after that day it
never was the same again
yeah yeah everyone was the same again
and we were young
um uh but many people young like we were
in similar situations did not survive
that you know survive things like that
it was really miraculous and then um
they're probably like
not millions of them but it's probably
probably had some pretty close calls I
can't that's the one that you say and I
remember it but if I tonight I'll
probably remember six or seven other you
know you know it's funny that our
conversation before this is one of the
reasons I like asking that it's an
interesting thing to kind of contemplate
and think about tell me a name droppy
story I know you work with so many
incredible uh musicians you were telling
me you're about to open for Ringo in
Boston oh yeah first of all what's wrong
with name name like people have written
like people and I used to be like
they're named but then I thought about
it and I was talking to a friend and
talking about another friend and the
friend said well he's really name-droppy
talking about our mutual friend I was
like I was like but he's he really cares
about you and he's a great guy and and
that made me that lead me led me to to
the kind of like really Ponders like is
there anything really wrong with name
dropping like
if you're like holy holy crap like we
were having lunch dinner and Ringo Starr
walked up to our picnic table
yeah that's a great story I that's you
know it was really cool that was that
was a really cool experience and you
know when you get in a band or like you
must experience this like with what you
do for a living you have experiences
like these experiences like this and
then
like I got to the point where I wouldn't
tell anybody about them like we can only
talk about them in the band or someone
like you like
friends of mine who also experience
those experiences on a
on and I'm gonna say a regular basis but
the fear of jealousy or that you'll
sound like sound like a name dropper
yeah like a name dropper right they also
just be like my life well I saw you guys
at the bowl and David Crosby was
backstage I remember seeing it comes in
that picture comes up on my phone all
the time I never posted it but you know
how the phone sends you yeah
that was me him and me David Crosby and
Seth like there's a picture we took and
I'm like
that was so awesome that was amazing
yeah but does any stick out go ahead
well one time uh we played Jimmy Kimmel
Live and um I think I might have been we
wrote back uh uh this this woman Val
wrote back with us in our in our van uh
and um we had dinner with with Pete
Holmes
get the [__] out of here somewhere in
L.A
and I was like
I almost ruined it by being like I
really I was there wait Bob I was there
for that that is so funny what a great
and hilarious and gracious answer
um have you haven't done the the uh
Ringo shows yet or have you we did this
weekend yeah and what is hila is he
still enjoying his 81 or 82 and does
jumping jacks he is light on his feet
he I mean he runs out on stage and he
runs off the stage and he and he plays
drums like like he's 25. wow it's it's a
is exciting to watch him to say that
this is possible
this is possible and he exudes gratitude
and joy
and you sense that and I know he's been
through a lot of a lot of tough things
and you I just sense that like whatever
because again with the Beatles like they
were the only four people experienced
that
and it was isolating and it was
difficult
you know it was a blessing but it was
also a curse and they all they all had
things they had to go through in their
life after that and um
he is strikes me as being uh reconciled
with it and
grateful for it and he I sense he feels
blessed to be doing what he's doing
today so he he exudes Something
Beautiful
hmm do they play Octopus's Garden
uh in the set I don't think they
actually played it in the set so it's
all stars so it's like Colin Hay from
Men at Work plays one guitar the great
Steve lukather who was in Toto plays the
other like probably one of the greatest
guitar players in the history of Music
this guy he Thriller album like Toto was
the band for the Thriller album like we
can't forget that like Toto wrote you I
never knew that what yeah yeah yeah wow
incredible but just uh so so they do
like hold the line Rosanna and Africa
and they do um
the bass player for The Average White
Band so they do one of those great funky
instrumentals
um is it Edgar Winter plays the piano
Johnny Winter past play guitar I think
Edward Edgar Winter plays piano if I get
that wrong I'm so sorry but so they do
free ride
which everybody knows Free Ride yeah of
course
um Frankenstein that great instrumental
Frankenstein
oh sure okay um okay so it's a great
show it's like the greatest cover band
and then Ringo does like photograph and
the encores uh With a Little Help from
your friends and and we all we got to go
up there and sing you know and yeah it
was just it was you know I'm convinced
like we've not won a Grammy
um uh we've won like some other Awards
but but like I think no matter how many
records we sell no matter what we
achieve as the Avett Brothers the most
Cherished Memories will be I'm gonna
name drop being on stage with Bob Dylan
at the Grammys you know recording with
Rick Rubin being on stage with Bob Weir
being on stage with Ringo like these
like little things that
don't make or break you
but
they are the icing on the cake they're
just they're the Beautiful Moments that
that you just cherish yeah wow what a
great answer
um let me see I think we're we're there
last question can you tell me
a time in your life when you laughed
really really really really hard maybe
you were a little kid
maybe someone fell down
maybe someone farted these are the
prompts I give well it doesn't have to
be a great or a classy story no this so
so
um
my son's he'll turn 11 tomorrow
and I have great memories from being
that age or around about there and you
get a best friend like that's kind of
when you get a best friend you know and
um having
your friend come over your house and
you're just this funniest the stupidest
thing makes you laugh to where you're
crying and you got snot coming out of
your nose and you can't catch your
breath and so I have like moments
memories of of those things like that
and then like but similar to that when
when we started the band
um Scott was was dating his his now wife
in Greenville North Carolina and so we
would play there frequently and often
the end the week ended with with me and
Seth driving back together
and we were driving my in my truck my
Toyota Tacoma pickup truck and we would
just it was that that adolescent humor
that we would just come up with things
and we would just be laughing so hard
that we were crying and we experienced a
little bit of that this weekend
and um to be you know and and that so so
I won't I can't say a specific Mo I can
think of many moments no you're talking
about all that feeling like that feeling
of just like this is so stupid but for
some reason this is where my humor is
this is this is this is one of the
things that makes me grateful because
when I'm touring and I'm with an opener
and we're laughing there's a parallel to
those sleepovers you had when you were
your son's age and that is something to
be Ringo Star level grateful for what a
cool answer I love that it made me think
of one maybe this will make you laugh
when I interviewed
um Seth and Scott I it was in Scott's
studio and I I had met Scott before yes
and but I was walking into a studio for
the first time and the first thing I saw
was a giant painting of him naked it was
a new yeah and we both I mean it was a
great painting and and there's no body
shame here but I mean there it is sort
of like and here I am naked and we were
both sort of looking at it and I went
there's a a beat of silence and I just
went did you fluff before that you fluff
it up a little bit and he went oh yeah
you gotta fluff up before anyway and we
just laughed so
like but it was like you had to address
it you
you naked painting of me right there I'd
have to be like Bob thanks for doing the
podcast that's me naked I did uh you
know I tossed it around just a little
bit before I did it and then and then we
could do the interview but that came to
mind as you were talking about laughing
with those guys and it was like they're
great they're great for that yeah and
they're great for making funny lyrics to
their songs and other songs and I
believe it and there ain't no ham
right there's there's there's just uh
I really appreciate those guys for for
being like that for being like that I
believe it it's special
what you guys have especially in what
you're creating is special and I really
think this conversation is going to hit
people in in a really hard to reach part
of the heart and I'm so glad that Josh
Church the wonderful Joshua oh yeah this
idea yeah it's a good idea just so he
could list so talk about the ego so
selfish so he could listen to this
conversation himself man son of a [__]
no he made it happen and I'm so glad he
did
um Bob would you say keep it crispy it's
how we end the guest says the
catchphrase and then we'll be out keep
it crispy
do you need another one no I love that
keep it crispy I love that you think we
needed another one it was perfect thank
you so much my friend I will absolutely
see you guys next time you're through LA
and maybe we'll go out to dinner again
either way I'll be there just for the
church just for the church I'll be uh
I'll be name-dropping it after we do it
[Music]